bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
r je recommence bonjour premier jour de
campagne officielle donc aujourd'hui
pour eric zemmour il l'a officialisé
hier dans une vidéo regardez
il n'est plus temps de réformer la
france mais de la souris
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
j'ai donc décidé de solliciter vos
suffrages devenir autre président de la
république
des semaines de suspense effet qu'est-ce
que ça va changer concrètement arcure
parise
bah ça change tout puisque il ya une
différence majeure entre
pensée espérer quoi qu'il y aura le
candidat eric zemmour et puis le
constater vidéo à l'appui une vidéo
forte en émotions en images en
références historiques donc cette
officialisation de sa candidature
effectivement je crois qu'elle change
vraiment tout ce qu on a aussi pu
constater sur le terrain lors des
déplacements d'eric zemmour pendant
cette croisée des chemins que beaucoup
de gens doutaient n'était pas encore
convaincu absolument qu'eric zemmour
serait candidat et donc cette
officialisation va rassurer absolument
tout le monde et donner un élan
extraordinaire un nouvel élan est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça tomasz
orlowski
qu'est ce que ça change d'ailleurs dans
la dans la campagne les républicains et
à droite largement moi je fais d'accord
il ya une officielle de campagne et
il ya beaucoup de gens qui j'ai encore
en discuter mais est-ce qu'il va
vraiment être pour l'idéal maintenant il
est vraiment pris d'assaut c est le bon
chemin je pense qu'effectivement il est
difficile depuis que votre thème c'est
l'union des droites de savoir ce qui va
se passer tant qu'on n'a pas je dirais
le deuxième maillon de la corde qui est
le candidat qui sera désigné aurait pris
fin samedi prochain normalement parce
qu'il devrait y avoir deux tours une
bibliothèque un jour bien la vidéo une
bibliothèque la cinquième symphonie de
beethoven une mise en scène qui
ressemble à l'appel du 18 juin pourquoi
ces choix concrètement arthur parisse
se sont effectivement il ya ya ya ya
d'autres si d'autres clins d'oeil
d'autres références
sont des choix forts puisque c'est un
moment fort selon nous de l'histoire de
france un moment de bascule
où eric zemmour déjà décrit dénonce
annonce depuis 10 ans 20 ans les
problématiques auxquelles notre pays
fait face et surtout le manque de
responsabilité politique depuis les
vingt trente quarante dernières années
qui n'ont pas su prendre en
considération ce dont j'ai l'immigration
l'identité l'insécurité
de la souveraineté et donc je crois que
c'était nécessaire effectivement
d'user entre guillemets de de certains
clins d'oeil pour aussi rappelé toute la
dimension historique ce cas on ne pourra
pas enlever à eric zemmour cet amour
qu'il a pour l'histoire de france et la
capacité qu'il a pour la partager avec
les gens qui la suivent depuis qui le
suivent depuis des années et dont je
fais partie donc je crois que ces
références là était était importante
pour un moment important et pour un
espoir important pour les français ont
parlé d'espoir eric ciotti a réagi on va
le voir après on va d'abord regarder la
réaction de marine le pen à cette vidéo
où eric zemmour y égratigne tous les
candidats sauf eric ciotti marine le pen
et jean luc mélenchon envoyé ce qu'on a
dit marine le pen
j'ai trouvé cela passéiste et
crépusculaire le rôle du futur président
est de construire la france du xxième
siècle un petit côté passéiste on l'a
entendu il ya pas mal de réactions
arthur paris sous vous êtes d'accord
avec ça ou pas ou c'est vous c'est voulu
disons que oui et ce qui est voulu c'est
la référence culturelle à l'histoire de
france et pas que culturels politiques
sociologiques et c'est maintenant un bon
marine le pen est dans son rôle quand
elle est allée dans ce rôle d'opposant
toute concurrence entre guillemets la
course à la présidentielle d'eric
zemmour passé je n'aime pas ce mot parce
que il a un petit côté un peu galvaudé
six
ce n'est plutôt que de dire que c'est
une référence à la belle histoire de
france à la grande histoire de france et
à
l'immense patrimoine culturel français
oui en ce sens là la vidéo est une
grande réussite tommaso qui on va on va
regarder la réaction d'eric ciotti à
cette vidéo d'eric ciotti qui
débattaient hier soir avec les quais et
les candidats de la droite républicaine
regarder dans ce clip il y à des
constats que partagent beaucoup de
français il y à des images que beaucoup
de français subissent il manque dans le
clip une espérance la responsabilité de
la droite républicaine et d'apporter des
réponses à ces peurs alors il est ce que
cette vidéo manque d'espoir est ce que
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cet
hommage au vote ce qui alors que arthur
parisse parlait justement de redonner
espoir aux français
je crois qu'eric ciotti il a compris
beaucoup de choses pour voir ce que
donnera le congrès et son sens en ce
constat est juste si nous les bois après
il ya une vidéo c'est une manière de ses
calanques contrat il faut marquer le
coup il confond pas avoir validé est
partagée par les candidats les
républicains hier soir voilà donc y
aller on
[Musique]
n'arrive pas forcément
japon ce musée des coudreaux
voilà pardon
dans la modernité voilà en tout cas on
s'adapte oui donc oui effectivement il
manque une espérance on peut pas tout
dire dans un clip mais je pense qu'au
delà de ça c'est intéressant si tu y es
eric ciotti parce que j'aimerais que
dans le nord de profilage politique nous
avait dit qu'on allait parler du monde
et droite c'est un des rares candidat
des républicains avoir compris que
c'était absurde de dire que eric zemmour
n'avait rien à voir avec valeur pour
après reprendre 80 % de son discours sur
l'immigration
lui au moins il assume lui qu elle n'a
pas changé il voit la mort fait partie
de la famille de la droite ils peuvent
avoir des différences vivement je pense
qu'on s'en être anti zemmour acharnée le
clip hier était quand même assez sombre
je connais les questions sur
effectivement par rapport à l'image qui
là si ça aurait pas été le moment de
donner plutôt la touche d'espoir même on
va faire des commentaires de
communication politique n'ont plus qu'un
camp c'est le fond moi ce que je trouve
on doit se retrouver nous à droite
pourquoi elle me soutenir les ricains
le racing nationale et eric zemmour pour
défendre quand vous les français pour
défendre et d'espérance et aussi
répondre quand même à cette gauche qui
comme insupportable moi j'étais les
réactions moi j'ai oublié le nom d'un
journaliste de libération hier qui
disait cet actif de gens qui ont la
haine et s'est arrêté bon ça peut être
un clip un peu violent il peut y avoir
des choses qui croit tout réussit enfin
la réalité c'est qu'ils aient ma
sécurité darryl et qui provient
largement l'immigration politiquement et
largement et qu'il ya des choses qui ne
vont pas notre pays et c'est les
français qui manque d'espoir qui m'ont
tous les candidats maintenant dans cette
campagne vont devoir faire des
propositions donner une vision et et on
est le pays vers le haut arthur parisse
d'ailleurs sur eric zemmour a été
interrogé hier soir au 20h sur sur tf1
on l'attendait en tout cas les
commentateurs disent depuis des semaines
on n'a rien sur son sur son programme or
hier soir aucune question sur son
programme qu'en avez vous pensé de cette
interview
ab j'espère que vous ferez la
gentillesse et l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de considérer que votre
confrère gilles bouleau
absolument poser aucune question à eric
zemmour sur son programme donc
effectivement
quelle ne fut pas notre déception qu'a
un moment aussi important à une rendez
vous médiatiques aussi important qui le
journal de 20h
son journaliste phare gilles bouleau ne
soit pas capable n'ai pas envie parce
que ça montrait plutôt le manque d'envié
qui l'avait d'interroger directement sur
des problèmes de fond il a préféré
touché la forme la surface et 7 c'était
c'était décevant à l'égard de gilles
bouleau en revanche j'ai trouvé moi
justement eric zemmour
parfaitement dans son temps son rôle
dans son statut ceux qui s'interrogent
depuis plusieurs semaines depuis
plusieurs mois sur la mue du journaliste
aux candidats moi honnêtement c'est
vraiment fière que je trouve qu'elle a
pris toute sa grandeur toute son
épaisseur s'est tenue j'ai vu le camp
dit eric zemmour avec la dimension
historique et importante que revêtait
pour lui la course à l'élection
présidentielle donc une déception sur le
réquisitoire qui n'était donc pas une
interview mais un procureur gilles
bouleau mais en face eric zemmour calme
serein et qui n'a pas oublié de relever
que c'était dommage de rater ce moment
pour poser des questions essentielles et
répondre justement sur
sur des idées de campagne dont on sait
qu'elles sont très fortes et qu'elles
sont très nombreuses et sur lesquels on
interroge trop peu et régler moi
peut-être que ça va changer on l'espère
en tout cas mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu naïf de croire que les journalistes
ne vont pas sûr que ce qui peut susciter
la polémique et il y en a eu des
polémiques ces derniers jours la page
est tournée là ça y est il faut faire
table rase et recommencer c'est ça
non je n'ai pas faire table rase et
recommencé à se dire que maintenant on
est dans un deuxième temps il ya eu ce
premier temps de la précampagne de cette
croisée des chemins qui a été un moment
honnêtement extraordinaire c'était le
déplacement d'eric zemmour dans beaucoup
de villes de france à chaque fois des
milliers de personnes des conférences à
guichet fermé sur lesquels il est plus
égrainé ses idées sur des sujets à
chaque fois diverses et variées ont dit
qu'ils ne parlent que d'immigration
c'est faux il a parlé d'économie
d'éducation de politique internationale
et j'en passe donc nous on retient
surtout cette ferveur et cet engouement
populaire qu'a suscité cette croisée des
chemins et maintenant effectivement
c'est un deuxième temps à temps qu'on
espère depuis des mois nous les
militants que les français espèrent
depuis des années mais mais je fais
partie de ces français là est donc cette
consécration de cette deuxième de ce
deuxième temps se fera au zénith le 5
décembre
tomasz zukowski est ce que les réserves
de voix d'eric zemmour a priori
puisqu'il a quand même aussi entre 13 et
18 % selon les sondages on verra puisque
les sondages ça évolue et puis ça se
trompe aussi donc en tout cas il ya une
vraie dynamique eric zemmour est ce que
ça pourrait constituer une réserve de
voix pour la pour la droite ou linverse
alors bon je vous ferai pas sur les
dynamiques puisque je dirais qu en
politique c'est un peu comme la météo
bretonne ça change assez vite donc là on
est plutôt un refus il faut quand même
être honnête pour différentes raisons
soient parents ne soit plus sous jacente
et structurelles notamment la capacité
d'eric zemmour a rassemblé autour de lui
mon voile a pressé la campagne comme je
lui ai dit ça ça va et ça vient
sans électeurs ça pourrait être
potentiellement les les vôtres bas j'y
allais je sais pas qui sont les biens
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est qu'on a plein de la droite et
c'était ça dont je voulais parler sur
l'union des droites c'est que on a trois
options le bloc de marine le pen le post
eric zemmour et le bloc du futur
candidat des républicains qui
malheureusement ne se parlent pas encore
passe son temps à ça leur temps à
s'affronter et l'union des droites
également de l'autre qui pensent à peu
près la même chose déjà les républicains
une large partie d'entre eux pas tous
pas eric ciotti que nous on soutient au
congrès on va voir les résultats mais
une large partie d'entre eux ont
reproduit le piège tendu par mitterrand
à la droite c'est à dire l'espèce de
front républicain de ne pas vouloir
parler au rassemblement national qui
femme aujourd'hui avec marine le pen est
très différente mais jean-marie en tout
cas ne serait ce que dans le staff et
des choses comme ça et maintenant
je termine on pourrait pas non plus
parlé à eric zemmour enfin je veux dire
on devient fou certains aux républicains
deviennent fous en refusant parler
d'eric zemmour valérie pécresse en
refusant la journée du conservatisme de
devenir dans la même salle d'eric
zemmour pour parler aux militants des
républicains et en faisant du théâtre
d'anti fascisme d'opérette donc ça tant
que ces temps que les républicains
n'auront pas compris qu'il faut
dialoguer avec tout le monde quitte
éventuellement à
à exercer des différences même six mois
dans le fond j'en vois pas tellement
c'est plutôt dans le style on n'y
arrivera pas donc si vous laissiez ans
ce pas déjà et se passer d'un bloc de 15
à 20% de marine le pen s'ils veulent se
passer d'un bloc de 10 à 15% d'eric
zemmour en plus des dires de 35% des
électeurs français enfin qu'on nous
explique comment les républicains je
répète une partie des républicains
puisque pas tous entre 10 et 15%
d'intentions de vote ne veulent pas à
s'allier avec des gens qui avec des
forces politiques qui composent 30% des
français en plus sur des thématiques où
malheureusement certains des
républicains ont perdu tient de
crédibilité lorsqu'ils sont passés au
pouvoir donc au lieu de s'allier et de
regarder tous ensemble comme on peut
battre emmanuel macron certains
continuent à
sur le devant de la scène où l'art se se
présenter comme des parangons morale en
disant dans le monde ces gens là sont
pas bien ils sont pas fréquentables bon
ben on va encore perdre pourquoi aussi
ne change pas on va voir emmanuel bach
rend donc j'espère que le congrès sera
l'occasion d'un sursaut et qu'avec
ciotti arrivera en tout cas en suivi
dans votre position pour pouvoir faire
changer cette politique arthur parisse
vous y croyez vous à l'union des droites
avant la présidentielle
disons que non il ya des droites je sais
pas si elle doit
elle doit avoir un nom peut-être qu'elle
prendra une matérialité naturel en
fonction effectivement pour rebondir sur
les propos de monsieur des dynamiques
puisque bien malin qui peut aujourd'hui
prévoir ce qui se passera et la cama
rendez vous important qui sera l
élection du chef de file des
républicains donc tout ça de jouer dans
un sens comme dans un autre maintenant
aujourd'hui nous en tout cas de notre
côté l'important c'est qu'on considère
que qui récuse amour est le seul à
pouvoir porter
ses grandes idées de la droite est
aujourd'hui c'est le seul surtout
absorber la bourgeoisie patriots
l'électorat populaire et un tiers des
abstentionnistes donc on voit bien que
cette synthèse eric zemmour aujourd'hui
arrive à la complète et donc nous pour
ça qu'on continue depuis le début de
plus et sa candidature et maintenant
quelle officielle en continue de pousser
le candidat parce qu'on est convaincu
qu'il est le seul aujourd'hui en
capacité de faire cette centaine
joséphine baker est entré au panthéon
hier ma france c'est joséphine a dit le
président de la république eric zemmour
a été interrogé sur cet événement et à
regarder
joséphine bancaire avait un prénom
français et surtout c'est l'exemple même
de la réussite du modèle d'assimilation
à l'ancienne que je veux restaurer et
que nos élites et en particulier
emmanuel macron des tests et rejette
eric zemmour qui a ajouté d'ailleurs
pour moi joséphine baker c'est la france
pour répondre au mode emmanuel macron
qui a dit ma france c'est joséphine
quelle différence finalement entre ces
deux phrases est ce que vous en faites
une tommaso vote ce qui bat wil a pour
le coup il y a quelqu'un comme une m
emmanuel macron qui file la récupération
politique franchement consternante et je
comprends pas qu'on ne tape pas dessus
face est vraiment la pauvre joséphine
baker quelqu'un d'extraordinaire qu'on
exhume comme enfin façon complètement
anachronique comme comme étendard de
l'antiracisme enfin vraiment c'est chaud
ça déplorable franchement et genre c'est
ma france c'est à dire que les autres
ceux qui n'aimeraient pas joséphine
baker sur des bus bon voilà je vais
alors que pour le coup là la formule
direction moi je trouve que c'est
presque la meilleure formule hier à
l'interview oui ben joséphine baker
c'est la france comme d'autres c'est
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire il faudra
peut-être aussi qu'on arrête de regarder
sans arrêt de la couleur de peau c'est
moi qui rajoute des personnes j'étais
assez elle parlé à beaucoup de monde
voilà et donc donc je pense que là il ya
quand même une différence de niveau
entre quelqu'un qui fait de la
récupération politique qui pour le coup
récupère le passé pour le tordre dans le
présent pour faire de la petite
politique politicienne est quelqu'un qui
répond sur le fond et de façon assez
sincère qu'il a parlé de son enfance
qu'il la voyait à la télé je pense
qu'avec des mollahs il a claim franchise
qui et ses bons côtés d'eric zemmour
quand il répond comme ça répond
sincèrement en tout cas a priori arthur
parisse la phrase d'eric zemmour versus
celle d'emmanuel macron vous en pensez
quoi
j'en pense honnêtement c'est pas
nécessaire de faire un duel de deux
phrases ce qui est certain c'est que
joséphine baker et
évidemment éminemment l'incarnation
dans son parcours dans la vie qui fut la
sienne le modèle
des simulations à la française cette
femme qui a fui un pays à six en tout
cas ce qu elle comme elle le disait
ségrégationniste et donc qui a rejoint
la france pays des libertés et surtout
pays de pays où elle ne fut jugée ni sur
sa couleur de peau ni sur ses origines
et qui l'a accueillie si bien que
hollande viendra des dizaines d'années
plus tard
une femme à rentrer au portant donc dans
l'histoire des grands hommes de la
nation et des grandes salles de la
nation française donc pour moi c'est un
grand symbole c'est un beau symbole et
j'y vois une résonance évidente avec
eric zemmour en tout cas avec ce
discourt eric ciotti on va finir
là-dessus eric ciotti qui demanderait à
laurent wauquiez de devenir son premier
ministre s'il était élu regarder
je crois à l'énergie en la force de
laurent wauquiez et je crois de plus en
plus que je serai amené à lui poser
cette question j'ai été heureux de
travailler aux côtés de laurent wauquiez
c'est un homme de droite c'est un homme
d'état c'est le meilleur président de
région aujourd'hui
réaction tommaso ce qui est après avoir
arthur paris c'est un bon choix
je dirais batteux sur laurent wauquiez
il faut quand même se souvenir qu'il
avait été élu par les adhérents des
républicains plus de 60 70 % donc quand
on est en train de se présenter à des
primaires internes sa part louis temps
en tout cas bah oui ça parle ça parle
aux militants si la plupart ont pas
encore digéré le départ de valérie
pécresse et de
donc oui ça parle à peu est ce qui se
dira il est pas encore résident les
parents à
mon affection pour laurent wauquiez par
ailleurs ont apprécié la ligne carnet
par laurent ruquier au républicain je
parle et donc le oui je pense pas assez
habile et d'autre part c'est assez
cohérent dans le parcours d'eric ciotti
donc ce n'est pas non plus quelque chose
qui sort de son chapeau là dessus après
oui je pense que ça va les faire
permettre de marquer des points eric
zemmour était et est élu arthur parisse
laurent wauquiez pourrait être un
premier ministre lui a posé la question
hier il a dit que pour l'instant il
n'avait pas deux pas de nom
oui les voici c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu difficile de de se prononcer
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il a
parfaitement répondu ce sera fait en
fonction du dynamique des des hommes et
femmes qui seront amenés à le rejoindre
dans l'émoi dans les mois qui viennent
moi sur le révoquer je suis originaire
de grenoble donc c'est un présent de
région que j'ai forcément des serments
suivi ce qui est certain c'est qu'il a
un vrai le courage politique puisque il
a toujours su assumer les idées de la
droite notamment quand il était
président de du parti à l'herbe il a
aussi accueilli à l'époque
chaleureusement eric zemmour pour qu'ils
puissent aussi y faire une conférence ou
plusieurs conférences donc ce courage
politique de laurent wauquiez
effectivement il faut le souligner il
est important et les sur son important
quand chez un parti dans un parti a
l'air on voit bien que cela devient
maintenant c'est genre maintenant
appartiennent à la minorité de leur
parti merci beaucoup à finir sur ces
mots à merci à tous les deux en tout cas
d'être venus débattre en direct ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france